it's a conversation yeah but I sometimes
I feel like you're like making some good
points and then I interrupt you and then
you're like what was it talking about
I'm never making good points yeah you
are on top of your dumb head all right
ah hey guys welcome to the minimalist
podcast with sweeter causes your new
host
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you've been nagging
me every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bear that you
refining about it
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists welcome to episode
number 69 today we're going to talk
about sex no wait a minute
what is episode 69 but it is actually
one of my values we're going to talk
about we're going to talk about values
and but before we dive into that we had
today we're recording this on April 2nd
we had an April Fool's joke yesterday
and I just want to say thanks for
everyone who sort of participated and
laughed and smiled and shared it with
their friends and family the cool thing
about that April Fool's joke is it's one
that will live on I think you can share
it beyond now we did something called
the nothing app our our friend Matthew
Vela came out came to us and said hey
are you guys doing anything for April
Fool's this year and so last year we did
like this minimalist t-shirt was 729
dollars and if everyone who would have
bought it purchased one we would have
made like 6 million dollars but anyone
who clicked the Buy Now button last year
it took them to an April Fool's page
right because we don't sell t-shirts
especially a $100 t-shirt my god and so
this year Matt came up with the idea of
doing the nothing app because we all we
think it's a bit quixotic to believe
that technology is going to solve our
problems with technology we've created a
bunch of Technology problems let's solve
it with our technology sounds like a
South Park episode or something right
yeah and so we came up with the nothing
app and it's an actual app you know a
lot of people didn't know this when they
saw the video so you can look go look at
the trailer if you haven't already it's
just the minimalists calm slash app we
put it up in the podcast feed as well I
know our website was crashing yesterday
Ryan because so many people were trying
to download the app
well what's funny is the people who did
download the app I didn't see on Twitter
for some of them were like is this an
April Fool's joke err not like it was
they were still deciding this half
doesn't do anything
aha it's called nothing it does exactly
what we promised so yeah I think that'll
live on if you didn't get a chance to
participate in the fun then you know
feel free to go over to the minimalists
comm slash app you can see the the two
minute trailer to that and you could
actually download the app as well if you
really wanted to it literally does
nothing so a screen
we actually it took a lot of work to
create nothing you know into the
voiceover Matt did three days of filming
it and by the way he did a behind the
scenes of how to make a nothing video it
took in three days and a whole like
camera crew of people and editing and
all this other thing we come up with a
joke we commit if you have to man you
get all the way in on the joke so you
can check that out also speaking of
April 1st
it wasn't an April Fool's joke our
documentary minimalism is now available
worldwide whoo yeah man so welcome to
all of our new listeners worldwide we're
glad you decided to join us you may want
to go back into our podcast feed you
don't have to listen to all 68 other
episodes unless you want to that's great
too but you can just sort of tweeze out
the ones that are most interesting to
you some of the most popular episodes
we've done so far are on clothing the
finances episode the children episode
the technology episode and also the the
parenting episode we've got a bunch of
other ones in there as well you can
check that on the iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube or wherever you get podcast make
sure you subscribe and if you really
love the podcast if you enjoy it then we
would appreciate a five star review as
well all right Ryan before we plunge
into today's show let's just get this
out of the way let's talk we're going to
talk about values today and we're going
to be answering some questions from you
all but I just want to put this out
there right away values isn't isn't
necessarily synonymous and I don't want
it to be synonymous in this conversation
for morals or morality or for religion
we have people from all different
religions different walks of life Ryan
and I have different
religious beliefs we probably have
similar morals but our values are a bit
different our values go on on top of
that so values are somewhat amoral they
can be moral
they can also be immoral someone a
psychopath can value something that
doesn't actually serve the greater good
and so when I when I talk about morality
what I really mean is serving the
greater good when I talk about values I
mean what adds value to my life and the
lives of others so morality could be a
value morality could be a value yes yeah
yeah it definitely could in fact one one
would argue that it's a great value to
have is to live a a moral life or to
serve the greater good also I just read
this from Seth Godin it's super short
it's like two sentences but it's a
perfect essay to kick off to today's
show it's called all we have to do is be
the person we say we are that's the
title of the essay which is just about
as long as the body of the essay I love
Seth because he does these little pithy
blog posts that just make you think and
they change your perspective and a
couple sentences or a couple paragraphs
so here's what he has to say we'll put a
link of this in the show notes no need
to shop for a better you or to work
overtime to make bigger promises keeping
the promises we've already made is
sufficient and I think that's what my
values are for me my values are in a way
a promise to my future self here's the
person I want to be like the most I want
to be my 40 year old self and and
aligning my actions with that self is
really promising myself yeah the
promising me that I am I'm going to live
in accordance with with those values and
so today we're going to really uncover
what that means what is the value and Oh
before we jump into the the Cobblers
Ryan a couple of quick updates from well
two things one is where I already
mentioned this so I don't have to
mention it again that's nice
or on Netflix already so I've already
mentioned that wait a minute April
Fool's not Groundhog Day right okay now
the second thing to mention is
we are hitting the road one week in one
day from today well from the day this
post Solis we're headed out for the less
is now tour we have proposed 47
different cities 19 of those we've
already announced tickets are available
for the first 19 cities over at les is
now calm Ryan and I are going to give a
talk about minimalism we're also going
to record a live version of our podcast
and answer all of your questions or at
least some of your questions while
you're on the road we'll dish out some
free hugs so come on up and say hi after
the event as well
tickets cities dates all that good
information over at les is now calm all
right let's jump into the questions here
our first question is from Rob in
Pensacola Florida I was hoping that you
could provide a definition of what the
phrase add value means on one hand it's
a pretty intuitive idea yet because it's
used so often on the podcast I think
having a definition provided very
helpful because it is it could become
very subjective where it means either
nothing or everything so when discussing
what add value means might even be
helpful to talk about why something
about adds value or how something adds
value all right so what does adding
value mean and is it subjective well
first off yes it is certainly subjective
I wish that I could say well here's my
prescription for values and here are the
100 values that will make me and you
live a meaningful life first of all that
sounds daunting that's overwhelming yeah
right and and so I don't have a
prescription for you because the things
that was boring to if everyone had the
same values it would be boring right
because we'd all be living the same
exact life and we'd be robots and so I
don't have a prescription for you but I
can tell you what some of my values are
and some what are the different areas of
values as well so you need to get clear
on what what does value mean to you so
to me Rob value just means if something
adds value to my life it serves a
purpose or it brings me joy it's not
then there's not a value now we have to
talk about different types of values
because there are some
you that not all values are created
equal some are certainly more important
in our lives than others and so because
it is subjective we you need to
determine what are your values and so my
partner and I Becca she she and I have
been sitting down and really going over
this exercise of looking at the
different types of values in our lives
in fact she's working with a lot of her
clients now over a minimal wellness and
helping them identify what their values
are as well as part of their their
health plan it's part of it's just
helping them get a clearer mind set on
what they what they want and so she put
together this worksheet that I think
will help people out if you go to
minimal wellness comm slash values it's
the same sort of formula that the Bex
and I use to identify what our values
are
but Ryan there are four types of values
that we've identified these are like
different categories of values
yeah or so that helps us take a little
bit deeper into what values actually are
because I could see where maybe for Rob
it gets a little confusing where you
know the sixth extra pen that he's
holding on to will one day add value and
the others I'm certain that some people
go down the rabbit hole of like talking
themselves into every single thing that
they have does add value in some way so
yeah to help identify how valuable those
things are I think that this approach is
really can help yeah so just to continue
an example whether it's the pin you may
get I have a pin here with me I get
value from that pin but I don't get the
same value from that pin as I do from
our relationship right so relationships
are a value but a tool like a pin is a
value how do i distinguish those well
there are four categories that we'll
talk about here and we won't go through
each of our individual values in detail
but we'll at least give you some
examples here so first off you have the
foundational values now Ryan and I wrote
about those values the five most
important we call higher-order values
and for this point the point of this
exercise I'll call them foundational
values we identified five higher-order
values that helped us live a more
meaningful life health relationships
creativity or passion as we refer to it
in our in our book minimalism and then
of course growth and contribution I
think all of our values serve either
wrote their contribution in our lives so
whether it's a tool or it is just your
health in general or creativity these no
matter what it is it's going to serve
either other people you're going to be
giving in some way contributing in some
way or it's going to help you help you
grow as an individual and so those are
the foundational values the higher-order
values those are the values you need to
really live a ideal life and at least
for me those values identify to to live
that ideal life it's the foundation upon
which we which we build and then from
there you have three other categories
what I'm going to call core values minor
values and imaginary values okay so
let's think of this like a house yes
okay so the foundation values that is
the slab of concrete that is what
everything else sits on yeah so I know
for me if I'm feeling discontent or you
know feeling unhappy or confused
whatever it may be I know I will go back
to those foundation the foundational
values and I'll ask myself like where do
I sit with these like how much attention
am I giving these values and quite often
I will discover like oh you know what I
don't the last time I talked to my mom
was a month and a half ago like I really
need to call and see how she's doing
yeah I haven't talked to my brother in a
while I need to give him a call or Ivan
I have an added value to Josh's life
lately yeah I'm going to get him some
coffee or something so that's why I
think the foundational values are so
important because everything else rests
on top of those yeah and if you have a
weak foundation everything else is going
to crumble right absolutely and so the
next the next set of values would be
your core values I would also call these
your principles right this is like the
framing of the house the walls maybe the
Yabba room set up definitely and maybe
even like some of the drywall and these
these core values are your principles
and we often hear that word principle
used to describe it's almost used
interchangeably with the word values but
I think a principle is a type of value
these are what keeps the house held up
in your metaphor there right and so just
a quick example some of my my core
values are autonomy and certainty and
communication and compassion and freedom
and free speech and gratitude insight
integrity intimacy
ability morality we talked about earlier
morality can be evaluate for me it's one
of my core values here a morality
quality better but fewer things right
respect sexuality significance solitude
trust truth and variety and now for each
one of those I won't go through the
detail but I have a one sentence
definition for each one of those it
should be tweetable you should know your
values and they're strong enough to live
up to a tweet basically right and from
there you can expand on them if you want
but my definition so I'll give you a one
one example see here free speech the
ability to say yes to what needs to be
said now that's how I define free speech
that doesn't mean you pull out the
dictionary in fact I would encourage you
to hide your dictionary I want you to
define your values for you what is what
does free speech mean to you if that's
one of your vibes what is mobility me
and for me its unfettered by geography
right and so not being tethered to to to
a place necessarily right and so these
are my core values what are your core
values you want to get really clear on
that those are the principles that hold
up the the facade of your house right
and so that would that be the next
category there the the minor values to
me the my minor values make life more
interesting aesthetics and coffee is of
minor value from your concerts
entertainment music reading social media
now that that can fall into the next
category as well so any of these can
really a style teaching technology tools
and in parentheses I have useful
possessions next to tools that's what a
tool is for me it's a possession that I
actually find useful it could be a
literal tool like a hammer or it can be
a lamp that I use to light up the house
that is a type of tool so these minor
values are it's like the artwork on the
house it's the front it's the furniture
in the house it's like not necessarily
things that you you have to have to live
right but things that you need in your
life to help make your life more
interesting and more enjoyable yes there
there once that are justified because
they're deliberate once in your life so
you've questioned these things and you
know that I do truly give value from it
it's not a core value I can
without it it's not a need my bed it's
like I could sleep on the floor
uh-huh great but like I really find
value in my bed yes I'm more comfortable
in my bed than I am sleeping on the
floor exactly and so we're not we're not
here propagating a life of asceticism we
don't want you to live in perpetual pain
and suffering and or deprivation even
what we're trying to uncover here what
are the things that actually do add
value to our lives one of the tools one
of the aesthetics and so yes Ryan it
could be the artwork could be the
furniture it could just be the paint on
the exterior of the house of the bricks
or whatever the facade of the house that
those are the minor values it's the
things that make life more beautiful and
more interesting and the fourth category
is imaginary value these are the
obstacles in our lives these are the
things that we've pretended are valuable
to us but they actually get in the way
of what our real values are and they
force us to miss prioritize our life in
a way that we're allocating our time to
things that we pay lip-service to we say
that that it's a value but really it's
not a value at all because we're not
getting true value from it it's it's
keeping us from living the life we want
to live our foundational values
relationships but yet when we're around
our significant other friends and family
and we're always on social media and
that's preventing us from investing into
that foundational value then we've got
to be able to look in the mirror and
like say hey that might be an imagined
value like that social media or for me
it's news that might just be a
distraction from the things that are
truly important so like going back to
that example with the sixth Penn for
example so so let's say that Rob he
writes down all of his values and he
kind of puts them in these different
categories well that's when you can take
things like that sixth pen or maybe it's
a sixth junk drawer and ask yourself
like is that serving any of these values
here that I listed out and if it's
something that serves an imagined value
then again like we've got to be honest
with ourselves and ask us if it's
actually something we need to spend time
on I think maybe the thing I would ask
there if we do have an imaginary value
so some of my imaginary values for
example are chocolate chocolate is in
that because I taste good to me
and I am able to enjoy it but it
sometimes gets in the way of what I am
any of my other sort of health goals
would be right and so if it gets in the
way then it has been an imagined value
where but the question is can I make
that a minor value for me
it sure is yes because I will
temporarily deprive myself of that and
I'll limit myself to the amount of
chocolate at all are you unwrapping
chocolate underneath the table right now
what sure insert chocolate overlapping
noises you know so so for me like
chocolate so that's an actual thing
within there other other things that
aren't things efficiency is a imagin
value I think but also you know we're
trying to be efficient get things done
go go go go priority is our productivity
is another imagined value on here we try
to be productive all the time we're busy
busy busy but we're not really effective
we're doing things that are meaningful
and many of the things that we do eight
the form of productivity but don't
actually allow us to produce what we
want to produce they don't serve our
values so email is a good example for me
right now that's probably a minor value
but it is very rapidly slipping into the
imaginary values because it stresses me
out and it gets in the way of my other
values and and you know I'm interested
to see can I live a life without email
even and if so what what does that look
like and so I'm going to start asking
questions about that because with these
imaginary values you either want to move
them out of your life altogether or
figure out how do they become a minor
value in your life and because it needs
to go one way or the other
becoming a minor value means I found a
way to use this more effectively found a
way to use it so that it serves my
values instead of getting in the way of
my values and let's say scarcity is
another imagined value from the
imaginary value because then as soon as
like I I get into that let you see it's
most pronounced with commercials
obviously Riley actonel supplies are
limited I better act now be ready and
like it Spurs you to take action which
is okay in some cases but most of the
time it's imaginary they're still
interesting then your
like that what a what a brilliant
marketing technique I never looked at it
that way but it forces you to make a
decision
uh-huh like it forces you to a decision
that has not been in your life so you
sell that advertisement all of a sudden
it's like you need to decide right now
there's only there's a limited supply do
you want to act on this or not yeah
you're going to miss out other Wow yeah
and so scarcity is one and there are
other things for me too like Instagram
or YouTube YouTube is definitely an
imaginary value for me the way that I
use it like I would just binge it and so
I found a way to make it a bit of a
minor value by turning into
entertainment entertainment and
scheduling an hour a week to just like
sit down and what an Indian Rap Battles
yes sometimes cats day is my favorite
Canadian rapper but uh anyway it's
really about determining what are one of
those things that are getting in your
way right now and the things you're
pretending or valuable to your life that
aren't so Ryan I'm sure you had had many
of these back in in your life of
yesteryear where it was you know some
sort of t-shirt or something in your
life where you're like yeah I'm going to
use that someday I'll hold on to that
yeah I mean yeah like yeah you've
mentioned t-shirts it's like I think
back in the corporate day every single
event we went to we got some type of
like corporate logo t-shirt here welcome
to this event have a teacher they're
incredibly uncomfortable - yeah like
really they were never it never fit
right but you know it was great to have
for yard work or like if I was doing
some you know drywall or painting around
the house or something like it was nice
to have a junk shirt yeah you're not
going to wear out in public really right
so there were there was a certain value
there but when I had 20 of them there is
no there's no value with 20 of them you
ever wear all 20 of them at one that
could be an interesting experiment like
putting all 20 on the realize how absurd
I think there's a YouTube video some guy
doing huh you like put on as many shirts
as you good anyway I know but I mean I
think writing out yeah writing out this
list it does help you to get more clear
on okay what exactly is
valuable to my life and what am I just
imagining has value Lake you know back
in the corporate days where I would just
drink every single day as much as I
could to get that nice drunk feeling so
then I could go to sleep at night wake
up and like you know do whole day over
again yeah and you know now so I would
say that at that point like alcohol was
this imagined value and now I'm at this
point where I'm out with Mariah
especially like when her sisters with us
like we were in Chicago we went to her
restaurant that she works at and she
like brought out this sorbet and she's
like oh you're going to want to have
some Moscato with that with that sorbet
now Moscato
I know you don't drink Josh Moscato is a
very sweet wine it's a dessert wine okay
um you typically you just you typically
don't just sit there and drink glasses
of Moscato um it's so incredibly sweet
so that's like something that I never
would have ordered off the menu in my
life but with the sorbet with that in
that Moscato like it totally elevated
that entire meal like I had no idea that
you could pair a wine like that with a
dessert and just like somehow make the
dessert better and I really enjoyed it
now am I going to go out and have you
know buy a bunch of bottles of Moscato
now and have sort of a Moscato every
single night no but it can certainly it
certainly can be a at least a minor
value I won't think I would ever call
alcoholic or value but a pleasure but
it's I mean yeah my mom would have and
may she rest in peace but I even for her
I wasn't even imagine actually alcohol
is not even imaginary she knew it was in
the way Billie she couldn't stop doing
or chose not to stop doing it shouldn't
say couldn't she certainly could have
continued to drink throughout most of my
childhood and it was unfortunate but
like at some point that was the other
would thing to like it was an imaginary
value but it was truly just an obstacle
for her right
and it definitely prevented her from
from living her best life she was an
outstanding woman but that she had this
ten-foot wall on the way of her values
yeah so
yeah I guess just reiterating like
that's why I really love the idea of
approaching values in these four
different categories is because it does
help us realize what is actually adding
value in what is getting in the way
exactly
and so sometimes things will slip from
this has happened to me recently things
will slip from the minor value section
to the imaginary value sunjin thousand
the sauna this morning with this woman
from South Korea and her and I were
talking she's like hey it's all your
documentary and actually there's a lot
of people in japan and korea who like
your work and I'm like thanks and and
she's talking about how in South Korea
in particular how it's become very
Americanized and there's just few
generations ago I think the average
income was I guess for the war was $64 a
week or something oh wow it was a really
small amount and and it's changed
appreciably since then right so it went
from deprivation to abundance and then
beyond abundance and excess right and so
as a culture of deprivation that quickly
transitioned to a culture of excess and
what she was talking about was that
you're getting those basic comforts and
you need those to have some certainty in
your life that's one of my values a
certainty image and that right and so
once you get beyond that base level of
comfort though people stuff become
uncomfortable with the comfort they've
created in their lives the smartphone is
a great example it's a wonderful tool
for me and being able to listen to
podcast and share a photo or whatever
but also I was at so yesterday I took
Ella to the inflated house and it's me
and a bunch of other parents who were
just like sitting on these bleachers
watching kids play right and it's like
Lord of the Rings or Lord of the Flies I
mean it's like just kids going crazy
and we're spectating them sort of like
gladiator actually and so as a respect
hitting them I noticed that every parent
who's anywhere nearby is on their phone
I mean not most of them everyone and so
I'm like cool it's fun time
Ella's down there play and she's busy
and I'm like wait a minute
what are you doing Josh
do you need to do this and that's a
question is the need does it actually
add value does it serve a purpose or is
it going to bring me joy and no wasn't
serving a real purpose that served my
values it was pacification and it in
that moment my smartphone was an
imaginary value it it would have not
made any difference whether or not it
was in the car and so I went out and I
put it in the car and got her snacks for
her while I was out there and before I
did that though I took one photo and put
it up on my Instagram account so that
can be an imagined value as well I did I
just went did a quick boomerang thing on
on Instagram and just shared an
Instagram moment real quick and she's
like right now take another picture and
like no we're done with pictures now and
say put but her mom's taking more
pictures I said that's fine and they're
allowed to do that I'm not judging them
and she was kind of smiles at me and and
and runs off and I have the one picture
from that and then the phone goes out in
the car and I'm done with it and that's
turning that that thing that could be an
imaginary value back into a minor value
it's about using it more deliberately so
Robin love to give you a copy of our
book minimalism live a meaningful life
will send you either the audiobook
version if we have any audible download
codes Shawn you can reach out to him or
the the book book version we hope you
hope you enjoy that our next question is
from Matt in Lexington Kentucky when you
place all your identity in your
corporate job just like you guys talked
about and you know you even minimalize
that part of your life right a minimal
have that part of my life is where's the
jobs concerned how do you go from
changing your identity where it is all
about corporate America and how far
you've made it and those are the things
that you talked about you know and how
do you change from that to your identity
into something else I don't know if that
if that makes sense I'm trying to figure
out what is my identity You Know Who am
I without being this thing that I put
ten years of my life into you know Josh
if Matt went through this exercise of
writing down all his values and putting
in putting them in one of these four
categories I bet you if it's not in
is foundational values then it would be
in his core values of being someone who
contributes something you know more than
themselves
someone who needs recognition yeah
significance is a value that I have on
mine yeah and I think everyone needs to
feel significant to a certain extent for
sure yes and being accepted right so you
know keeping that in mind the question
is is how can you take those things from
your corporate experience mat your your
job title well not from your job title
but your actual job right what can you
take from there like with me I remember
going through the same thing and I'm
like wait a minute like I really love to
lead I really love to contribute I
really love to also be accepted and
these are the things you love to buy
yeah I love yeah I need to be be
significant someone else's life and I
was able to do things like you know dude
go to the food kitchen or contribute to
like big brother big sister or maybe
it's another community project Matt like
just look at look at the things that you
can incorporate into your life that will
still fulfill these these needs that you
have but instead of it being you know
20% of what you do find something where
you know that's 60 70 80 90 percent of
it yeah it's about really making that
shift and so you know it's interesting
because my shift happened while I was
still in the corporate world because we
asked these four words and this single
question I think it's a rather
pernicious question it's what do you do
when you meet someone for the first time
that's one of the first things that we
hear what do you do and then we give
whatever our title on our business card
is and then that person recites back
their title in their business car we
stay the next five ten 20 minutes
talking about our vocation there's
nothing wrong with that we all have to
earn a paycheck but our identity thing
gets wrapped up because we answer that
question so frequently and I had a good
answer to that I'm the director of
operations for 150 retail stores and
that was an impressive answer but it's
not the only thing I did when you asked
what do I do well I go to concerts I
read books I write I eat dinner with my
family
what do you mean will I do all your
saying where do I work so I can compare
you to me on the socio-economic ladder
and when we posit the question that way
it totally changes and so what I did is
I change the way that I answer that
question I spent a year experimenting
when someone came up to me and said what
do you do I said I'm really passionate
about X now for me that X was writing
but it's a great experiment I've had a
bunch of our readers have tried this in
the past where instead of telling people
what your business title is tell them
what you're passionate about and then
flip the question around say what are
you passionate about now you might get a
deer in headlights at first right you
might get the but I was going to tell
you my bit here's my card
here's and and all of a sudden you have
to get past that little barrier but once
you do the conversations become a lot
more meaningful because you talk about
what you're passionate about doesn't
mean you make a living off of it if you
do that's great sometimes there's an
intersection between vocation and and
passion and that can be wonderful but
it's not necessary either so if you want
to change your identity one of the
things you really want to do is start
changing your answer to that question
talking more about what you're
passionate about yeah I'll tell you how
I answer that question is instead of
saying I'm really passionate about X
what I'll say is is you know I really
love to snowboard what do you love to do
yeah yeah and asking someone what they
love to do it is like you know they're
not going to bring up work right I mean
maybe they do and they do live with what
they do for a living which is great
there are certainly cases like that but
happen but I got to tell you I have very
rarely had people reply with their job
title um although I will tell you though
it did I have and I guess you've
probably experienced this too or even
you know you answer with my passionate
about this were you passionate about
eventually they'll be like yeah but we
do for a living do you make money I'm
like are you asking me how I make money
is that is that what you're asking
that's a weird question it really is man
yeah you're like what's your social
security number right um yeah it may not
be that important you know and so my
question is that that would be then why
do you want to if we could talk about
how I teach a writing class so so that's
part of how I make a living
let me understand your question butter
is something that I would say to that is
Oh what do you want to know so that I
can help direct the conversation and
that way now when you're having this
conversation with yourself Matt there
are five questions that I asked myself
early on when I was making this
transition trying to shift my identity
the first question I asked is why not
give so much meaning to this stuff now
for me that was actual stuff physical
material possessions stuff stuff but
then also like other stuff how I spend
my time
why why am i giving so much meaning to
this stuff this lifestyle that I've
created right and then the question the
follow-up question of that is what's
truly important in my life and that's
different from why have I given so much
meaning to these things in the past what
am I going to focus on what is truly
important in my life
the third question I asked is why have
I've been so discontented because I
created what's supposedly the ideal life
but I wasn't contented by it I felt
overwhelmed and stress and because I was
living by someone else's template right
and so why haven't been so discontented
and you fall off that question with
who's the person I want to become
now that means what is my template not
someone else's template right then
ultimately the fifth and final question
I ask myself is how am I going to define
my own success and and that question
allowed me to say okay
it's not this American Dream it's not a
number of likes or followers or money or
any of these arbitrary goals that that
are successful to me if I'm not happy
because success without happiness as
Tony Robbins says is failure and so you
can be as so ostensibly successful as
you want but if you're discontented with
life is that real success no for me
happiness is is growth and contribution
and and and and being willing to to
acknowledge that that's ever changing
and if I don't if I don't realize that
that's always changing
then I'm going to become stagnant and so
my values are going to become clearer
and shift over time as well and
ultimately I need to make sure that I
align my daily actions
with a person that I want to become I
think that if you do that that's how
you're going to uncover what what your
identity is we'd love to give you a copy
of our book everything that remains that
it's right and I moved out to a cabin in
the middle of nowhere Montana like five
years ago and started writing this book
about our five-year transition from
being the suit-and-tie corporate guys to
becoming minimalists and it was a heck
of a time but in that in that process
especially in the middle chapter seven
and eight in particular we really had to
start questioning our identity so in
there is the story of us questioning our
own identity and how we made that that
shift as we as we jettison the the
things in our lives started filling our
life with what was truly important we'll
send them a signed copy of the audio
version the next question is from Andrew
in Vermont I was really unhappy for
about seven years
and so as I had unhappy marriage unhappy
life at last spring made my wife's soul
pretty much everything we had and we
took a six-week trip across the United
States with our two toddlers and now I
live back in Vermont I have a completely
different job and I've really embraced
the minimalism point of view my question
for you today is about values in the
past years that you've been a minimalist
and identified as that have you found
that your values have changed and how do
you how do you deal with that and what's
the best way to deal with that so
Andrews story reminds me of a story that
I was telling on Facebook live the other
day Ryan we were having one of our
Mondays with the minimalist sessions we
were answering some questions and to me
as a friend he does canning or what
they're they're jars but we call it
canning but they're mason jars
and I want to call it Nathan jarring he
does jarring with like foods foodstuffs
right I love food me too and so but if
you have a whole basement full of these
jars before you put anything in them you
have to boil water and sanitize these
things so they're clean but if you boil
the water and sanitize these these jars
and put them back on the shelf for a
month they're not ready a month from now
right and it to me that was the perfect
metaphor for minimalism because Andrews
talking about how they sold all their
stuff and then that would have been the
first step getting rid of the clutter is
the first step but it's not the end
result
you then have to figure out what to fill
it with once you've sanitized your life
so to speak you have to figure out the
fill within and then he filled it with
some travel he and his two toddlers and
his wife went took that six-week trip
and and man he found more happiness in
his life and now that he's back in back
in Vermont he has a different job he's
saying okay have my values change and
he's asking us guys did your values
change once you embraced minimalism and
I think for me the short answer is no
but my priorities changed so not my
values but my priorities and also my
beliefs change I think of my beliefs as
the pathway to get to the values and and
that's why Ryan and I have radically
different beliefs about religion and
also about politics but we have similar
values we get to the same place via
different pathways and I've recently
been writing about this and thinking
more about it as not just a like a road
pathway but more like a waterway and the
water sometimes it gets redirected as
your beliefs change if something this
comes and plugs up the dam then all of a
sudden your water is going to move in
different place your belief is going to
change you're still headed towards your
values most likely but your values
rarely change it tend to solidify and
for me my values with minimalism once I
got the access out of the labs able to
see clearer and more clearly identify
what my values are and put it into
practice and writing them down and then
trying to live that life in accordance
with with my values and now whenever I
feel discontented I realized it's easier
for me to determine why because I'm
not living up to my values and so
because it's easier for me to determine
why it's also easier for me to to fix it
maybe not easier it's simpler for me to
fix it because I'm able to identify what
the problem is and that's the first step
in in offering any sort of solution yeah
no I totally agreement yeah my values
again the short answer is no my values
did not change once I went on this this
path of minimalism and introducing this
philosophy into my life what it helped
me do is be honest with myself I'd help
me to like look in the mirror and really
get clear on like a what my priorities
are and to act on on those priorities so
no I I don't think I don't think my
values changed but but yes certainly I
just have a much clearer picture now of
what I need to focus on I was just
thinking about this family I didn't know
what my values were really I mean I
probably could have rattled off
something that I would have said or a
valueless oh well my health is important
obviously right right but I was 80
pounds heavier and I was eating fast
food and and loaves of bread and yeah
and I'm like oh my relationships are
important but my mom lived a half hour
away and I you know might have seen her
like six or seven times a year yeah and
it I mean I didn't really do good job of
fostering relationships lip service
priority as we call it well Andrew would
love to see you man if we're going to be
on tour the less is now tour a bunch of
different cities but the second city
we're coming to is Burlington Vermont
and we hope to see you there we've never
been to Vermont one of two states we've
not been to so we're excited to see you
there Andrew if Sean if you reached out
to him maybe get him a couple tickets if
he's she's able to go for anyone else is
interested in seeing any of those other
tour dates it's just a less is now calm
that first little wave is I mean
Pittsburgh Burlington Boston Portland
Maine and from there
we're dispersing all throughout the
country having a bunch of a bunch of
good events so we hope to see you all
there all right we'd love to hear what
you all have to say so if you have a
comment or a tip about values including
advice for any of our callers today then
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm where our favorite
comments and
tips on the next episode and guess what
time it is time ISM it is time for our
hashtag ask the minimalists lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media we are on twitter and
instagram at the minimalists and
facebook.com slash the minimus
during this lightning round this is
where Ryan and I do our best to answer
each question was just a short shareable
less than 140 character response we also
put the text to these minimal Maxim's in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our put the answers on social media if
you'd like Kiki wants to know it's hard
for parents to pass on the minimalist
ideals and the materialistic society any
tips ok so my short answer to this one
kiki is to demonstrate our values we
must do more than tell we must show and
really what I'm saying there is is you
can you can tell someone their values or
your values to you're blue in the face
they mean nothing without action to back
it up preach Kiki leading by example is
the best way to transfer our values and
beliefs to others hmm yes indeed alright
so if he wants to know how has
minimalism change your values like I
talked about this with with Andrew a
little bit but here's my more concise
tweetable answer minimalism didn't
change my values it helped me discover
what my values are yeah
minimalism helped me to stop giving my
values lip service and take action yes
indeed our last question is from Pia if
you are living by your values and not
happy how would you go about changing
things hmmm so I think it's quite the
quandary and I think that's maybe where
I was before yeah in the corporate world
Ryan so here's answer I would have given
myself at age 28 if you are living by
your values but aren't happy consider
changing what you value yeah I said
something similar I said if something
you value is making you unhappy you may
not value that thing as much as you
thought yes indeed all right well let's
move on to our added value portion of
the show this is
where we each recommend something that
has added value to our lives recently
Ryan what you got dude I'm about to
change your life and our listeners lives
we should just cut the podcast right
there
no but seriously that money continued to
be continued last time on the minimalist
podcast no my friend Avery show came
over the other night we had some of the
refugee I had a couple of refugee
families over and it's not like ten of
us um I went to sha Shu
she's from Eritrea I'm like hey if I
invite you over in your family and like
yeah this other family and couple
friends like we will you cook for us all
I'll get like all the ingredients she's
like yeah absolutely so she came over
and like referred nine or ten of us and
a but brought this this spice so a be
used to run a restaurant in Missoula
called the Silk Road it's it's no longer
open anymore but they have these spice
mixes that they sell I think on Amazon
so I know you can affect you get him
anywhere in the United States you
probably can get them overseas as well
but he brought over this Ethiopian blend
and like when Shashi smelt it she was
like oh yes I'm going to get like she
knew right away like it was a really
good spice so she just made like some
like lentils and like cabbage and
potatoes like very very simple dishes by
the way like they are like fasting
you're doing the air quotes with yes
raivo eating during their fast well
they're they're fast or something right
yeah like basically it's no animal
products out there you know me they do
vegetables only and then they eat like
it only certain times during the day so
like they definitely do do intermittent
fasting right um but it was just I just
can't wait till the next time they come
over and they're not on their fast
anymore uh-huh and even like she cuz we
were all like oh my god this is so good
and that she was like you haven't seen
you haven't seen nothing yet I mean she
didn't say like that but no she was like
she was like wait till wait till our
fast is over when I can cook some
chicken and steak and sauce until your
recommendation is for the Silk Road if I
throwed spices yeah there are they're
like eight or nine different blends and
they've got recipes on the website and
it is a game changer their app so it's a
game changer spice so we'll put a link
to that in the show notes
and just real quick I have two
recommendations or both they're both
sort of the same thing I remember being
back being from Dayton Ohio we'd always
see the famous person in Dayton there
was one famous person who lived in
Dayton that he actually lived in Delhi
hammering Oh Dave Chappelle and he has
been out of the game for the last ten
years or so but he had two new specials
come out on Netflix the past week or so
and man
they are both hilarious and offensive
and I certainly don't agree with
everything that he has to say but it's
to me it's a portrait of a man who he's
watching culture passing by he's aging
and I see this now too I mean he's what
ten years older than us but he he's
seeing like as culture changes I think
he's not necessarily ready for all of
that he just had some hilarious bits in
there to do when his whole bit like
where his 12 year old kid wants to go
see Kevin Hart
yeah Matt Hara Arena by the way yeah
dude that was so yeah yeah I'm not even
gonna start paraphrasing because I don't
want to ruin it for the audience and I
butch I butcher it right that's like the
out of those yeah that's the funniest
part right so yeah I'm I'm a bit biased
because I really love Dave's past work
and I can tell you this he's probably
going to offend many people but I think
that's what comedy does and a lot of
times it offends us it also makes us
question or in some cases strengthen our
values while Dave I really disagree with
what you said about transgender people
and that means I'm different from you
and I have different values it helps me
solidify what my own values are by
questioning those values you
strengthened it it's the opposite of a
straw man argument it's an iron man
argument you want to constantly
challenge your values and your beliefs
in your perspectives and you do that
through various different perspectives
and also I found most of the jokes
pretty funny too yeah yeah it was great
two minutes so they're they're both on
Netflix the the first one it took place
in LA and it is called age of spin that
one's in LA and the other one it took
place in Austin Texas is called deep in
the heart of Texas I hope you enjoy both
of those if you are ready to be offended
all right let's quickly move on to right
here right now this is where we talk
about what's going on a lot
of the minimalists if somehow you misses
the top of the show our documentary
minimalism is now on Netflix worldwide
also speaking of of series or a video
work rather Ryan and I have put together
this four-part animated web series
called simples
I did some voiceover stuff it's the
content that we wrote and elven Dante's
he was kind enough to to do the
animation on all of that and so there's
four episodes the first two are already
out right now the first ones about to do
list
it's called some day and then the second
one is about money it's just called
money you can find both of those and the
scribe to the rest of the series over at
our youtube channel youtube.com slash
the minimalists and we have one final
Monday with the minimalist left on April
10th 2017 on Instagram live and Facebook
live at 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time we will
see you there and that's right before we
go on the road for our lessons now tour
les is now calm for ticket information
and dates and cities and all that other
fun stuff last but not least
advertisements suck so our podcast is
100% advertisement free but you can
still support the show by either
donating at the minimalists calm slash
donate or if you love the show share it
with your friends and family and leave
us a review on iTunes thank you so much
we've received hundreds of reviews in
the last few weeks and we're really
grateful for that we're about to we're
not they're already hit the 2000 review
mark and love to get beyond 2000
five-star reviews in their future so if
you if you have just a free minute and
you do get value from this we'd love to
get a little bit of your support that
helps us reach more listeners more ears
Ryan
anything else to cover nah man all I got
are some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners
hi my name is Yasiin Dara I'm from
Winnipeg Manitoba
I'm calling leave a voicemail in
response to the episode on jobs there's
a common thread in your work that
relates to living a meaningful life and
a lot of the discussion around jobs
tends to relate to climbing and
meaningful work and I think a shortcut
to finding meaningful work is actually
to just introduce the elements of
helping people so pretty much any kind
of work so if you were to take any sort
of job and just introduce an elements of
helping people to the actual content of
the work that's a direct route to
finding more meaning in network in my
case I've done just that by by quitting
the the corporate job in order to start
a social enterprise and that's kind of
my my tip for this messages the concept
of a social enterprise is something that
people maybe want to familiarize
themselves with which is to say
physically conducting any sort of
typical business but perhaps structured
as a nonprofit where proceeds are used
to event some sort of social or
environmental cause and in that way
you're combining potentially the skills
that you've acquired in the context of a
regular job and coupling them with the
idea of helping people and I've found
that to be a really really great way to
find meaning in my work hi guys this is
Katie calling from Reno Nevada I've been
listening to a lot of your episodes and
I keep hearing these questions about how
to be a minimalist with kids and it
always makes me laugh a little bit
because it's like we just need to take
it to the next level I think I've two
small ones a five-year-old and the one
and a half-year-old and I've noticed the
only way they get stuff usually is if I
buy it for them so what I do as a tip
for other moms and dads and grandparents
out there is every time I'm about to buy
something I think how much value will I
get out of this and why am i buying it
is it just to placate them in the moment
is it to try to buy them off so I can
have five minutes of quiet time by
myself then usually the answer to those
two questions is yes and I put it down
and walk away
the other thing is kids don't need that
many clothes or that many toys really
that much I mean even with two small
kids
we're still a pretty minimalist taffy
household we don't spend that much money
on really anything except experiences
and our lives are a lot better for it
this is Elizabeth from South Jordan Utah
and I was just listening to your podcast
about friends and relationships and
particularly your response to Rebecca's
question about how to improve
relationships or move on after a
relationship and as someone who does
believe that relationships are one of
the things that we take with us when we
go so to speak I really appreciate your
advice on how to take inventory of
relationships to make sure that we're
all staying on the on the right track
and on the path that we want to be I
would add to your advice to Rebekah
though just kind of a cautionary word
that the idea of not settling can
sometimes turn into nitpicking and I
would say that that's a very fine line
but an important one to remember
that if not settling means that you have
such a long laundry list of traits that
you're never able to actually commit to
anyone you're going to have a long and
miserable dating life I would also add
that it's important to remember that
sometimes the people who are the best
for us are the ones who challenge us the
most and in many ways are the most
different from us I know that's been my
experience with my relationship with my
husband and I wanted to put that out
there for anyone else who's listening
that just because it might be hard or
challenging it doesn't mean that you're
settling in some ways I you might be
winning in those situations more than
others
alright Joe that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalist give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcasts
at the minimalists comm and if you leave
here with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening we'll see you next time every
little thing you think that's mean every
little thing is things that you mean
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'd be fine
without it every little thing that you
got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you be fine without so tear your
eyes
[Music]